hi everyone welcome back to the GameSpot
stage here at e3 2017 joining Dave and
myself is jeff strain from undead labs
welcome thank you we're gonna talk about
state of decay - great so you had a
reveal was it last Jake or fields last
year we revealed that the game was under
development yes this year were showing
gameplay for the first time behind
closed doors so what's what's the
reaction been like not only at the the
Microsoft press conference I was a big
cheer yeah but now you can see people
seeing more of the game yeah
well I'll tell you what's fun is that a
lot of the people who've come in for the
behind-closed-doors demo were fans of
the original right and so a lot of our
presentation was built around kind of
educating people about what makes data
decay different and then talking about
where we're taking it from there but we
got to skip a lot of that stuff for
almost all of them and just immediately
dive into the new cool stuff awesome
yeah so what new cool stuff can you talk
about and now previously there was an
emphasis on the groups of survivors and
building bases but now it looks like
you've really gone like 110 percent on
those elements well right so the the
thing we got to do was take a look at
the game and say what worked and what
are we going to double down on what
didn't work that we're going to get rid
of and there were definitely some of
those and then where do we want to
innovate and push it forward our goal is
always to be getting closer to that
survival fantasy to giving you the tools
in your toolbox to go put your own plan
together and go execute it and see how
good you really are because I think you
know we all think that we'd survive the
apocalypse right and so what we're
specifically showing here is some of
those areas where we took things that
worked and deepened them and doubled
down them and very specifically that is
the the RPG aspects of the characters
the other survivors that you find that's
much more deep and much more
sophisticated interacts with the
simulation and much more meaningful ways
and then the base building that's always
been a favorite of people playing the
game so you have far more options to
customize and build out your base and
start building kind of physical
infrastructure to help you survive the
apocalypse so what are the biggest
challenges from jumping from state of
decay 1 to 2 well we've had a few the
first big challenge was
had to start with the new engine and so
where I was usually with a sequel you
get the benefit to start where you left
off we had to do a lot of rebuilding
from the ground up and that's that's
never fun but I think the benefit is
that players can expect to see a much
smoother much more polished in much more
beautiful world but really you know
beyond that the biggest challenges have
just been how do we take this kind of
known formula and not just do the same
thing but instead bring in fresh ideas
and really innovate while still holding
on to that core of what made the first
one work you know everybody has great
ideas but it's picking the right ones
and judiciously extending the experience
so that you're still capturing the magic
of the first that's always the tough
part
I believe this is set 15 months after
the previous game that's right about
between 12 and 15 somewhere in there how
does that change the gameplay world and
is Luke gonna be rarer because if I was
already pillaged the area because it's
you know over a year later how is it
kind of changed the way you play yeah it
is the world has moved on you know you
are definitely dealing with not a fresh
apocalypse where you can still go into
the supermarket and find Twinkies
everywhere right you know now you have
to work harder for that and I think the
emphasis is more now on what is your
long-term survival strategy it's not so
much about getting to next week or even
next month
now the focus has shifted into what are
you going to do for next year and a lot
of the the base building options and the
character attributes and the things that
we're using to kind of deepen that
survival fantasy are built around that
more long-term thinking that gameplay
loop that is classically footify finding
survivors gather craft that gameplay new
classic in some games can just become
repetitive I know you guys are
introducing some new elements to kind of
break the cycle and [ __ ] punching into
that gameplay loop well we do that with
a couple of ways you know the first game
had a specific story arc with the
beginning of Medellin that uuugh flowed
through and instead of dk2
we want the story to be much more driven
by the simulation you know
your choices the particular survivors at
um in your community
have a much greater impact on the
narrative that actually unfolds but
beyond that you know there's this always
a strong mentality of [ __ ] happens right
and in the apocalypse no matter how good
you are no matter how well you have
things dialed in and you've got your
base humming right [ __ ] happens right
people freak out and kill two of your
other survivors and disappear into the
night with half of your supplies you
know sometimes a car gets stolen
sometimes even though you're being
extremely quiet you know
a wandering horde notices that there's
human survivors here and comes in on the
night and attacks your bait you know
sometimes the medicine that you thought
was you're pinning all your hopes on
turns out to be well past its expiration
date and not useful to you at all
so we do interject very judiciously
these kind of kind of fate events that
mix up and change the conditions a
little bit and it's not really us trying
to kind of screw you right it's us
saying that yeah even in the real world
right [ __ ] happens
how often are those events going to come
about because you can't obviously plan
for them but if I think as a player that
what to happen too often you would get
discouraged right so how you balance
that
well the keyless theta decay is always
when something happens whether it's one
of your survivors dying because as you
know instead of decay its a permadeath
game when a survivor dies that survivors
gone forever or one of these kind of
[ __ ] happen events I keep talking about
I hope I don't get in trouble for using
occasion well I don't mean with you guys
I mean Microsoft yeah uh anyway the
important thing is that you should
always be able to look at that and
understand why it happened and feel like
you were responsible for it right if
your survivor dies you need to be able
to say if only I had rested him sooner
or you know maybe made sure that my
ammunation was was loaded before I went
out there there should always be a
reason and I think it's the same thing
for these right if you know if you have
somebody who freaks out in the middle of
the night and takes off your stuff and
leaves you know there should be a reason
you should look at that say you know
what my morale was really low and I
wasn't paying attention to that I had
five people in my community who were
snoring every night and people were
getting sleep-deprived
should have taken care of that a little
bit earlier how can you take care of
people who snore uh well uh that's an
awful nasal strip yeah so you probably
can't unless you want to kick them out
of your community which is always a
possibility or you know shoot them which
is always a possibility but instead what
you probably are going to be looking at
is ways to mitigate that right build
another bunkhouse and separate them or
try to find things that positively
impact morale that you can kind of stack
against it so that the overall impact on
morale is high that traits like that
there's apparently over a thousand you
haven't rates what give me some examples
I'm sure this there's some major ones
and minor ones that ya play differently
well what we want is we want every
survivor to be unique they are all we
avoid the word randomly generated they
are procedurally generated right through
a very kind of thoughtful mechanism that
combines both negative and positive and
major and minor traits every character
has three kind of core traits when they
come in and those traits impact not only
that characters RPG skills you know
wit's shooting fighting cardio but also
could cause that character have
additional skills such as gardening
because maybe they were a groundskeeper
in a former life right but the the key
there is that they're a mix of positive
and negative and you kind of take it all
as it comes we want everybody to be
unique feel unique and what we find is
that player is given just a little bit
of that kind of flavor background
especially if they can see how it's
impacting the simulation and impacting
the characters they'll hang all kinds of
story on those characters and build
these elaborate backstories I do that
when I play XCOM every time I get a
grunt soldier at first I don't care but
when I notice that you know this one has
survived by four missions and maybe they
do something awesome all of a sudden I
care a great deal and I start creating
these elaborate you know personalities
for them and we see that going on with
this game as well and that's something
we very much want to capture so how's
that expanding the characters I know you
mentioned their abilities how did they
develop is it like a learn-by-doing sort
of thing like like win world if you want
them to be bear shooting then they need
to go out
shoot stuff yeah they're definitely some
of what we call the core skills you
increase your cardio by running you
increase your shooting ability by
shooting that's definitely a part of it
but but some of them are not designed to
level up in that way or they they level
up through things other than going into
the world and practicing like there's a
lot of correlation now between your base
facilities and these character skills
and so you know if if you have a certain
level of gardening ability than that
implies that you can build only a
certain size or sophistication a farm
right you couldn't take it up into
something crazy like hydroponics or
something like that unless you had a
higher ability in that and maybe you
increase that to research or through
finding a library something like that
with this many variables how difficult
was it to sort of place sort of
boundaries on the simulation so it
doesn't get completely out of control
well it's incredibly difficult and and
it's one of the things it's the bear
were wrestling right now right the
release date for this game is spring
2018 and a lot of that is going to be
spent in the kind of polishing and
refining that you know players want a
smoother or more refined experience this
time around which we're absolutely going
to deliver but also exactly this the
simulation is a a big wild beast and
only through playing the game constantly
do we get a feel for it when it's out of
control and the way we get it out of
control as we go into too much detail
right it's like maybe we're going way
down the rabbit hole kind of simulating
the impact of you know bathing in the
morning or something right and then we
have to dial it back because it's easy
to tip over the line and who cares right
like there are big things that matter
that impact the fun of the game and then
there are things that we could do that
ultimately don't really contribute to
the fun and it's drawing that line
through there that's part of the art of
making a game like this we talk about
variables the biggest variable being
like a human variable how have you
adapted an introduced co-op knowing that
two groups two people doing these crazy
things how is that going to work
together so the multiplayer design
instead of the k2 is is actually quite
simple it's very drop in drop out you
can come to my world I can come to yours
and in addition to that there's the
flare system which is when I'm playing I
can register to be volunteer like hey
I'm playing my game right now but I'm
also willing to help people out they get
in trouble if you're in the game and you
get in trouble you can just shoot a
flare gun and it notifies people who
have said that they're willing to be
volunteers and they can jump in the game
and help you out so it's a way to not
only very quickly and easily play with
your friends but also to meet some
strangers and kind of work together that
way you know obviously the game is going
to be set up to reward you for helping
people whether that's your friends in
their map or you know through this kind
of flare mechanism but the as with all
aspects of the game there's risk
associated with it state of decay is all
about wagering it's all about saying I'm
going to do X because I think I'm going
to get benefit Y and let's hope the cost
does not exceed that right and so when
you go help somebody
there will be reward the game will
reward you for doing that
but if your character dies in their
world just as if the character died in
your world that character is gone
forever yeah so it's it you know we
balance these things through that risk
reward cycle it's that friendly fire no
not in the traditional sense no now you
could do something grief II like
bringing some fireworks in and putting
in the front of your your host base and
you know drawing all the zombies but no
there's no direct yeah friendly fire so
you're very focused on
it's it's you against the zombies it's
no human enemies
yeah and that's always been the heart
and soul of the game right state of
decay is not a grim game you know the it
is set in the zombie apocalypse but it's
a game about humans working together to
overcome a common threat now there are
going to be different enclaves within
the game of other survivors sometimes
relations may be sour between those but
but yes profoundly and fundamentally in
the multiplayer design in the narrative
design and everything we do we really
want the game to be about working
together to overcome obstacles you
mentioned that's right let's go ahead is
that a conscious choice given that a lot
of zombie media as it were starts off
that way with the humans all working
together but ultimately disintegrates
into infighting and betrayal a lot of
the time and murder yeah yeah it is in
and you know the the truth is that you
have to watch out for that right we
modelled that every survivor has
personality quirks and beliefs and even
along the primary axis of the apocalypse
which is are you practical or are you
are you kind and ethical right like
where are you going to fall along there
because sometimes you have to say hey
look you know we can be nice all we want
but are we all going to survive or not
right as you play the game and make
choices those survivors in your your
community who agree with that choice are
going to be happier and those who think
you're being stupid are going to be less
happy and so you are making that choice
about how to manage that and the kind of
personal dynamics there the whole time
you're playing so that is a real factor
but but in terms of kind of the overall
goal of the game the goal is to mitigate
that the goal is to not make everybody
happy but at least manage it to the
point that you can survive together they
mentioned it's now a long term thing
you're thinking about surviving years
ahead
how is that influenced the the base
building are you making bigger things
are you building things like that's
going to last you a long time are you
going to see that that transition of
time and be rewarded kind of bunkering
down for that immense amount of time you
know we're certainly not going to try to
model years passing but for example
you know instead of decay to power and
gasoline become very real things and
being able to power your facilities and
have more sophisticated facilities
because your power you now have power is
there's more of an emphasis on that the
the the first one felt a little more
rustic
you know tents for infirmary zijn you
definitely still start with those kinds
of things but you're able to build more
sophisticated infrastructure and and
we're trying to capture that feel that
we can't really afford short-term
decision-making anymore with the
emphasis obviously looking to the future
then you must by so default the players
like the size of the map must be much
bigger because you have to go out and
scout further right so we actually we
have three maps each roughly the size of
the first game and we do that so we can
have a little bit more variability in in
the look and feel and biome of each one
and I think as we look to expand this
game over time rather than having to
kind of bolt onto a large contiguous
world we'll do that by introducing you
know new maps with very distinct flavors
from each other and how do those maps
interact with each other is it kind of a
seamless one area to another thing or
are you going to be working in that one
map and kind of that's where your base
is and you have to kind of work in there
go and come back yeah so you'll you'll
fundamentally play you know for a period
of days or weeks within within your
oneknob but when you move bases and
there are you know very strong reasons
to do so it will often behoove you to
explore in an area and go into
a new map location so the kind of way to
think about it is you're traveling to a
different part of the world and you know
it's it's not contiguous it may be 20
miles down the road it may be 40 miles
down the road may be 100 miles down the
road but but we get to skip all the
boring stuff in between yeah so you're
more like zombie surviving nomads going
from place to place trying to stay safe
that's right yeah no that should be
because the game is persistent right you
consume everything in the area
when you're ready to take that next step
and go pursue those higher goals
sometimes you have to move on to new
where there are new resources well that
persistency once once you've kind of
explored the world will it kind of
refresh and you be able to go back and
find more things or you kind of just
always moving forward you're always
moving forward yeah awesome
all right well Jeff thank you so much
for coming down and talking to us yeah
can you remind the folks at home one
state of decay too is due to hit uh
steady decay is scheduled for release in
spring of 2018 we can't wait cannot wait
thank you got so much I ain't got an
honor right bye-bye
for more on this year's e3 and all of
the biggest games make sure you stay
tuned to game spot